"Poplars on the banks of the Epte, Autumn,"...
..."Water Lilies," "Parliament, Setting Sun,"...
...three exquisite paintings by the impressionist visionary Claude Monet.
Each journey to cross the Atlantic at the turn of the century...
...to sate the pioneering demand for the artist's work in America.
Monet defied the artistic standards and practices of his day.
His signature brush strokes, expressive hues, enriched impasto...
...launched the art world into modernism, but not without resistance.
European critics challenged the French painter's innovative technique...
...and radical interpretation of landscape.
American artists, however, were captivated, most notably Mary Cassatt,...
...painter, printmaker and fellow impressionist.
Cassatt and company championed his tour de force...
...and urged American collectors to take note,...
...but it was the art dealer Paul Durand-Ruel...
...who proved the most responsible for Monet's success.
Durand-Ruel became the primary supplier of the artist's work.
And in 1886, the dealer staged...
...the most significant impressionist exhibition of its time in New York,...
...a pivotal moment in Monet's career.
The press declared him the undisputed leader of the new movement.
By 1913, the onetime rebel of the French art world...
...was now the master of modern art,...
...a triumph, a legacy, a foundation for what was to come.